you know august 31st will mark the 25th
anniversary of the accident to claim the
life of princess diana well now a new
documentary is taking a different and
unique look back at her time in the
public eye giving viewers an astonishing
and often painful re-examination of the
people's princess
diana is very big news everywhere she's
got the common touch for 16 or 17 years
diana was one of the most films and
photographed people on the planet
our job in the edit for the first six or
seven months really was just to watch
eight ten twelve hours of archive a day
look through there you see we see things
going on inside if you're
trapped
young william and harry on the beach
hiding their faces under baseball caps
and running away from the paparazzi
diana in a bikini in the backyard never
a moment of privacy these are just a
couple of the rarely seen moments in
hbo's new documentary the princess which
premieres tomorrow
she likes to be with people she likes to
be bloody
that's ridiculous she has been
humiliated she's almost like a silent
movie star she was able to non-verbally
kind of tell people i think how she was
feeling and and with a little tilt of a
head or the curl of a smile
sort of project our own private life
publicly the real takeaway looking at
these moments was seeing the inner
turmoil diana battle and as the monarchy
prepares for change and harry and megan
have stepped away this doc attempts to
answer how can mistakes of the past be
avoided do you after making this film
understand why harry reacted the way he
reacted he certainly talks about a fear
of history repeating itself i think
there are echoes there are reflections
[Music]